92 percent of members at Planet Fitness
never go to the gym and so one of the
brilliant parts of their business model
was finding out who is least likely to
use the gym and who's most likely to use
the gym and then what they did is they
figured oh all these people who come to
the gym all the time they use heavy
weights they use barbells those are the
Hardcore gym goers what if we remove all
the things that those people use and
then we can get way more people who
never use the facility at all and then
what do all these people want they want
pizza they only want the easy equipment
and so they catered something for
everybody else and everybody else
doesn't use the gym and so they made an
unbelievably profitable model where the
average Planet Fitness has 10 000
members and if people actually use the
gym they wouldn't be able to do it and
it only works because no one uses it
because of how smart they were about how
they picked their customer